qui pourrait croire convoque sur un
champ de sarrasin une impression de
déjà-vu pour sandra et renault car en
2017 la communauté a connu une des pires
inondations de son histoire l'a pas
acheté n'adopte convient on vibre et son
non plus on s'attendait pas à ça surtout
pas deux fois en trois ans si blanche
est surnommé daniel boone surveille le
niveau de l'eau par l'europe toi toi
capable c'est il parle toujours de route
alors qu'on est sur l'eau les piques et
servent de repères ici les riverains
sont résilients les inondations font
partie de leur histoire et est mal un
café on offre des tours de gondole pour
nous autres de la maison ronde et on
arrive en chaloupe
mais grâce à un minutieux système
d'évacuation d'eau la maison est au sec
ça c'est l'eau de la nappe phréatique
la pompe à maintient le niveau de la
nappe phréatique pour pour que sa force
sa qualité d'impression à peyrusse al de
la pression pour que le plancher cac a
reculé on parle des solutions mais se
souvient les pilotis ya un système de
drains intérieur avec pompe et pompes à
batterie il ya ce bloc de ciment à l'eau
est un vraiment belle solution oustric
chaque maison à ses solutions pour
combattre l'eau où on choisit les
services d'un entrepreneur local pour
installer ce système de drains la langue
de béton et terre à faire avec un grain
france à l'intérieur qui un bassin de
captation avec une pompe et une pompe à
batterie aussi au coq il ya un manque
d'électricité
puis l'eau est évacuée ça n'aurait pas
fonctionné c'est recommandé ça libère
complètement le jeu de service cloud cas
ces interruptions ou alors ça serait
déjà sur le recto peut être jusqu'au
plafond
ils sont secs n'ont pas été évacués mais
malgré tout ils sont en réflexion comme
beaucoup rester ou partir
combien une honda nation tu veux enduré
en fait ce sont là
c'est un paradis sur terre c'est paradis
peut pêcher tons dorés c'est la pêche à
glace l'hiver deux mois dans la ligue
sont répartis silca qu'on a des grosses
inondations
ceci que c'est un temps à passer un
courant c'est l'axé ce que je vois en
emea chez nous jusqu'à la prochaine
inondation ici à sa bodega qui sera du
canada oui